it's great to welcome to the program
today Justin Elliott who's been a
reporter with Pro Publica since 2012
where he's covered money in politics the
American Red Cross and the Trump
administration recently he's been
covering the taxpayer first act which
we've also been talking about Justin
great to have you on hey good to be here
so for people who don't know what is the
taxpayer first act what what does it do
sure so it's actually kind of like an
omnibus bill that makes a bunch of
changes to the IRS but the thing that
we've been focused on is it it in its
old version it would have put into law a
deal between the IRS and the tax filing
industry basically TurboTax that would
have among other things restricted the
IRS from creating its own sort of
government tax filing system that's
exactly right and we so Richard Neil
who's the congressman here in
Massachusetts has been involved with
this and sort of sadly I mean I like the
guy personally and he was like the first
when I started doing this show the first
sort of real elected official that I
ever met but I'm not particularly
thrilled with his role in this and it's
not necessarily a unique role I mean
this is actually relatively
uncontroversial within some sort of
establishment circles in the House and
Senate that they there seems to be a
sort of you scratch our bracket back
will scratch yours sort of crony
capitalist I mean it's like the worst of
the worst in an area that a lot of
people don't even know is taking place
in a sense yeah I mean so it gets into
this whole whole area of tax filing and
sort of you know the annual ritual that
we all go through of doing our taxes it
turns out that in a lot of other
countries no one really has to spend
hours filling out forms and doing their
taxes and the fundamental reason for
that is that the tax agency often
already has your data so if you're if
you're getting paid every couple weeks
and taxes are being automatically taken
out of your paycheck right then the IRS
already has all those numbers and so in
many other countries they have what
sometimes called return
tax filing which is basically the IRS
takes all the numbers now they have
pre-populates your return and then you
sort of just look at it and click okay
if it's all good and so the question
becomes well why don't we have that here
and the answer at least part of the
answer is that turbo tax the company
that makes it into it and the rest of
the industry have been lobbying against
that kind of system for at least 20
years at this point yeah and the so the
the way this works is pretty simple
which is if you make money off of a
process that is perceived as too
complicated to do or actually is too
complicated to do without these pieces
of software you're far more likely to
buy one of these pieces of software and
pay pay the filing fees now what a lot
of people don't know and correct me if
I'm wrong I'm going off the top of my
head if you make under some certain
amount of money a year it might be in
the sixty thousands federal filing
already is free and those companies like
TurboTax provide that free federal
filing but they just don't make it too
easy to figure that out for yourself
you're exactly right so basically what
what has happened is TurboTax and the
rest of the industry have made this deal
with the IRS it's called Free File and
the deal says two things first it says
that the IRS can't create its own system
so the government can offer you
essentially its own TurboTax or they
can't you know create something like
that and in exchange the industry is
supposed to provide free filing to
people this year was making under sixty
six thousand dollars which turns out to
be actually the majority of the country
yeah and then what you experienced and
when you actually go to choose the
version of TurboTax or whatever that
you're going to use it doesn't it's not
made evident that there is such an
option and instead you're immediately
sort of up sold with if you want to
maximize your deductions take advantage
of deduction finder if you have any
Schedule C income or did any sort of
work on the side you should get the
small small and home Business Edition or
something along those lines now
what's important to understand is that
that does not account for the state
filing we're correct me if I'm wrong
those costs are actually regulated at
the state level and are not free on the
basis of income it's so it's a whole
sort of complicated patchwork and so
that at the heart of it is as I
mentioned there's this program called
Free File that actually literally most
Americans seventy percent should be able
to use to file at least federally for
free but what what TurboTax Intuit the
company that makes TurboTax has done is
create a separate product that very
confusingly is called just free so free
file and free are different things and
almost no one actually finds the sort of
truly free free file version because in
two it advertises this other version and
if if you end up in this quote-unquote
free edition in fact many people will
end up having to pay 100 200 bucks even
though if they had just gone to a
different website it would have actually
truly been free and this is essentially
a significant part of the company's
business model at this point what's the
argument that the government makes for
kneecapping itself on this in other
words we can kind of try to infer what's
going on behind the scenes but what is
this sort of public facing explanation
that the government says we believe in
restricting ourselves in this way you
know that's a really good question I've
actually never heard anyone at the IRS
could dress that aspect of it I would be
very interested to hear their answer
maybe we've asked them about this what
they will say more generally is that
they support this program because it's a
public-private partnership where the
government instead of having to spend
money on creating its own system and
employing people will sort of lean on
this already existing private industry
that's that's offering this product for
free which sounds good and might be a
good thing if people were actually using
it but in fact something like two
maybe 3% of Americans who are eligible
for this free file program actually use
it so virtually no one who's eligible
actually uses it and we've never really
been able to get any one of the
government to comment done on you know
why those numbers are so low and sort of
what their thinking is in the program
this seems to me like one of those
things that is really negatively
affected by the way that our election
system works and the way that
appropriating money works because if you
want to it would take longer certainly
would be my guess than like a term in
the house to make this a reality if the
government did want to develop its own
system and software it might even take
longer than a presidential term and so
in the short term if you want to push
this forward you would have all of these
elected officials who are not actually
going to be around in all likelihood or
might not be around when it actually
becomes real but they have to take the
sort of political hit of saying they
want to spend the money and
appropriating the money and the you know
political football of debt and deficit
why bother right they can just accept
contributions from these industries and
keep doing what they're doing yeah I
mean so there's a there's a couple
things going on so first of all as you
know - I mean Intuit and H&R Block the
rest of this industry are giving a lot
of money to members of Congress of both
parties including richard neal there in
massachusetts who of course is the
chairman of the tax writing committee
Ways and Means Committee in the house
they're also spending millions of
dollars lobbying it's very much of a
sort of bipartisan thing another thing I
would note is that there actually is a
bill in Congress that I believe has been
introduced by Elizabeth Warren and some
others called like the Tax
Simplification Act or something like
that that would that would push the
government in this direction so so there
is legislation out there and the last
thing is that you know I think you're
right that it would be a sort of heavy
lift for first of all for Congress to
appropriate money to the IRS to
to sort of create its own system but
there is another option which is the
government could just sort of contract
with one of the companies to create a
system and actually the Pentagon already
does this if you're in the military
there's a whole special military tax
filing service that's just a contract
that is presumably much cheaper when
you're talking about how much money
people are ultimately spending then then
individual consumer is going to like
turbo tax com that's super interesting
it's like taking Medicare and expanding
it to Medicare for all it's taking the
system that's already in place for
members of the military and saying hey
we could conceivably expand this to
include everybody what else does this
Act the taxpayer first act do outside of
what we've been talking about so far
that maybe is less publicized but
important yeah so there's a whole bundle
of sort of technical and boring changes
to the administration of the IRS one of
the other kind of headline provisions of
it is a and I think this is one of the
reasons why I got a lot of Democratic
support also is that it it restricts
private debt collectors from going after
lower-income people who back taxes
essentially which apparently is a
practice that that currently happens
which I didn't know before I started
writing about this and I believe it also
gives some money to a to another tax
prep program volunteer tax prep for
lower compete which is called Vita so
there's a couple things like that but
it's generally you know this bill was
sort of non-controversial except for
this free file provision which after we
started writing about it and writing
about the company's practices and sort
of tricks to get people away from this
truly free version that provision
actually was stripped from the bill a
week or two ago so it's it's no longer
in there so let's go back to what you
said about debt collectors and people
who owe back taxes I want to understand
exactly what they're doing
the idea is that the debt collector
would target low-income people who owe
back taxes for what exactly do they
fraudulently claimed that they will help
them with their back taxes or are they
taking advantage of people who might
have other outstanding debts on the
basis that knowing they Oh back taxes
they might be more manipulatable in some
way my understanding of it is that
actually the IRS these days use actually
uses private debt collectors to go after
people who you know have not paid their
taxes in some previous year under some
so so they opened so they owed back
taxes and I believe this was something
that this is actually a recent
development the use of private debt
collectors in the last several years so
with this new what this bill does is it
says below a certain income cap we don't
want these private debt collectors going
after people it's something along those
lines although I think the details get
some more technical yeah I mean it's
amazing that so debt collectors and the
debt collection world much like the bail
bonds industry is just rife with abuse
manipulation and all sorts of shady
tactics and even at the base level the
idea that the IRS at all would be using
some of these agencies is a pretty major
concern and red flag to me although I
understand that focusing on low-income
probably makes sense because they're the
most vulnerable and the immediate yeah I
think this is also part of a larger
trend that actually by my colleagues
here at ProPublica and writing about
which is that the IRS you know obviously
no one no one's really excited about the
IRS and probably don't want to you
probably don't want ever personally
interact with the IRS but it's actually
been gutted in recent years the budgets
been cut they've they've had a huge loss
in the number of people that work there
so as a result things like the audit
rate for for the wealthy have has
plummeted you know corporate tax
collections have gone down so the this
is my sense is that the the the private
use of private debt collectors is one
small part of this larger story of the
IRS just being gutted and so they they
can't do basic functions anymore what's
important to understand is that that is
seen as a feature and not a bug by those
who claim to be about small government
and taking power away from the
government when it comes to taxation and
tax collection it's not that's not your
when I hear you say that that sounds
like a problem but there's a huge
political contingent in this country
that says oh that's good we want the IRS
to be hampered in what it's able to do
yeah that's right
and I think they would argue that you
know the agency is too large and it's
it's too strong we don't we don't want a
strong tax collection agency and this
goes back to you know to at least the
90s when you you may remember there was
a there were congressional hearings and
the mid 90s I believe about the IRS had
sort of gone out of control and that's
kind of the modern roots of this this
whole movement yep it's been around for
a while and it will sometimes resurface
including under the Obama administration
during the so-called political targeting
of on the basis of the political
orientation of nonprofits for audits
which we of course learned was not what
it was made out to be
Justin Elliott has been a reporter with
Pro Publica since 2012
he has been covering the taxpayer first
act recently justin great to talk to you
I appreciate your time thanks a lot